obama
we are
amazing welcome to to the uh fall estate
youtube live i'm jessalyn peterson
apologize for the late start but we are
black and black people are late
[Music]
i have with me david pakman he is a
progressive host
an executive producer of the
nationally syndicated radio and tv
program the david pacman show
and i wanted to talk to david pacman
he is a baby
[Music]
patman
he is a man
of
david patman
he is a baby
[Music]
david pacman
he is
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about being a beta male and being
an alpha male what are we talking about
here
there are males most men today yeah male
1 they think and act like a woman they
are emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's amazing they go along with
homosexuality hold on but holy whoa whoa
jesse well we gotta that's a lot
that's a lot hang on agree with
everything that's raw abortion they
think and act just like a woman a beta
male dog but another baby
doesn't because he's a logical thinking
and they're controlled by the darkness
of david packman
he is a baby
[Music]
david pacman
he is a baby
david pacman
he
[Music]
david patman he is a male 1
david pacman
he is a beta male 1
david pacman
he is
[Music]
you're not here to communicate i really
appreciate you coming out i'm going to
let you go it's a waste of time to talk
to you we're not communicating you're
actually like because you're asking
bizarre questions you're actually like
an idiot and you're wasting my time i
appreciate that i'm coming all right
thank you for coming by goodbye
[Music]
that's a progressive vote
all
[Music]
wow what an introduction really couldn't
uh couldn't hope for anything better
than that quite frankly
welcome everybody it is uh it's rally
night in america we are only a week away
from the uh
2021
elections there's really one major
election and a few other ones we've got
some mayoral elements and a few
different things
but the big race
which may have far-reaching implications
is the virginia
gubernatorial race
where it will either be
this radical republican glenn younkin is
that even the right pronunciation i've
never actually seen it said out loud uh
glenn younkin who is horrifying i mean
really really horrifying and we'll get
into that in a little bit it will either
be him or
it will be
kind of like
boring
you know milk toast
center left democrat terry mcauliffe
i would rather it be terry mcauliffe
and there is it has been asserted let me
say it has been asserted
that
a mcauliffe win because virginia is a
neighboring state to west virginia a
mcauliffe win might be seen as a signal
to joe manchin
i should probably kind of go a little
more to the left whereas a glenn
youngkin win
may be interpreted by joe manchin as i
should hold out because it seems like
things are pushing back to the right
i'm not saying that will be the case
but it has been asserted
um so you know we're gonna watch it so
we've got two rallies today
we've got the glenn yonkin rally
scheduled for 10 minutes from now and
then in about 45
his opponent terry mcauliffe will be
joined by president joseph r biden jr um
at another rally so we have two of these
at least one rally today will be
unhinged so like if you gave me an under
over of one on unhinged rallies i'm
taking the over assuming one
is
equal to or greater than
okay if people understand what i'm
saying thank you very much
so that is that
um we have been making an effort
with this is a new initiative
okay new initiative we're looking very
strongly at sinks and showers
to
um have a calendar of live streams many
times uh i get one of the the most
common emails i get is david sir sir
your wife is up in the air
when are you streaming live and i say
it's kind of whenever the hell i feel
like it you know um it's sort of like
getting the hell out of
the hell out of here
um but there are when there are
scheduled live streams we're going to
try to make a point of promoting it so
we now are going to be publishing this
to various um
platforms
this was a graphical element developed
by my colleague john
here on the team
um
and we'll do everything so like for
example right now this is like
streamception
we are in this stream as we speak
10 26 6 45 yeah this stream is happening
right now
and
as of today the only other stream on the
schedule is a week from today we're
going to be doing election results for
virginia gubernatorial and others etc
etc
so
as we had like we you know we could i
could even put in here
like uh
november of 2022 we're going to be doing
a stream you know i don't know how
useful it is a year out i don't know how
many people are planning their night on
the midterm election day but this is
something by popular demand that we're
going to try to do all right
so that's
a really great thing
uh what else
oh let me go yeah let me get right to
i'm gonna try not to fall behind with
super chats or
um
twitch messages so let's jump right in
zach says vincent racanello says metrics
are needed for lifting mask mandates
after winter especially with kids
approved for the vaccine yes so let's
get to that i i tried to
anticipate things that may come up
zachary putting us right in the
wheelhouse of this first announcement
fda this is just uh an hour and two
hours or so old news fda advisory panel
recommends fraiser vaccine for kids age
5 to 11 expecting
expecting approval on that very very
soon panel of independent advisors to
the fda recommends an eua for the pfizer
biontech vaccine kids 5 to 11. the vote
was 17 in favor one abstention
we are thinking that as soon as next
friday
by next friday it's plausible
that
five to 11 year olds will be able to
start getting vaccinated it will be a
kid's dose it will be a kid's dose
normally i'm against anything like kid's
menu that's gutter trash okay
the number one thing that should you
know we've got these picky eating kids
in the united states
um uh no kid's menu
okay you're not special
you eat a smaller portion of what the
adults eat vaccine
you get a smaller dose of what the
adults get please
uh you know you go to these beautiful
restaurants where they've got
um
amazing dishes
uh sir ma'am would you like the kids
menu yes yes oh bring the kids menu
mac and cheese
chicken fingers and fries
spaghetti with butter
get it out of here
okay we're not doing it it's just crazy
uh all right anyway let's move on from
that i don't want to upset uh parents
who are big on the kids menu but you got
to train the never even there should
never be awareness that a kid's menu
exists
shouldn't even be aware of it oh and
grilled cheese yeah kids grilled cheese
that's the you go to an asian restaurant
you go to an indian restaurant you go to
fusion
mac and cheese spaghetti with noodles
grilled cheese chicken tenders and fries
you got to be kidding me you got to be
kidding me that's how you end up with
picky kids all right
i'm 90 serious okay so there's like a
little bit of joking here but it's
basically serious all right other okay
so we got that out of the way we did
this
and we're monitoring uh we're monitoring
this okay good
um oh by the way another one you know
another one
you know this one that uh i hope none of
my friends who do this stuff are
watching who do this stuff with their
kids
it's so common it's like oh oh oh
little little susie
doesn't it that's too spicy for little
susie so then susie learns she doesn't
like anything she goes it's spicy
the right answer is
kids can eat spicy food
kids eat spicy food in thailand and kids
eat spicy food in india and kids
spicy can't be a get out of jail free
card oh little mordechai doesn't eat
fish
why oh kids don't like fish really i'm
pretty sure all japanese kids grow up
eating fish
these can't be get out of jail free
cards okay
um
yeah all right let's move on this is
this is upsetting some people
uh clip it all of that should be clipped
and posted to stephen kenneth destiny
bennell junior's subreddit
all right david can congress get
expelled other than article 5.
does article 5 cover um
prosecution
conviction i'm not sure
i'm not sure we should look into that
black wave says you're nyc we outside
you're watching you're watching the show
uh from outdoors that's cool
under over we would be 0.5 to bet one
unhinged rally exactly jeremy thank you
um
love the live streams thank you david is
he a data mail data mail is led by logic
and reasoning based on what data bears
out yes stephen thank you
and um
leedy lobotomy says love your streams
good sir
sir sure thank you very much i
appreciate that all right let's go over
to twitch and see what's going on here a
lot of people to thank already
let's start with robot laser party is
new member number one today via twitch
thank you this is blood
new member number two oh hold on robot
laser party has asked for a few more
cheese suggestions and i'm i am glad to
um
i'm glad to provide them
uh in fact i had this ready to go so on
the last stream i offered a couple of
cheese suggestions which some people in
the audience found
elitist the two suggestions were the
breberus argental beautiful french
cheese
and then as a less expensive but still
delightfully pretentious alternative to
leggio which is an italian cheese and
some people wrote in and they said sir
we loved it sure i don't know and then
some people wrote in and said those
suggestions were
to elitist so please give us some others
i i will give some more suggestions
right now
but i am going to warn you these also
are
slightly
pretentious but they shouldn't be too
too expensive so here's the first one
jasper hill farm
this is a fantastic
cheese maker in vermont
i will tell you specifically the ones
i've had that are really good
the harbison
incredible cheese it comes wrapped in
wood
or wood as uh as my dad used to say when
we first moved to the us a little
transposition of v w
um
that's a fantastic cheese harbison is
great the willow bee special wash and
the regular regular wash special wash
a steam cycle the all of the willow bees
are excellent
i've not had this one
um the cabot cloth bound if you're into
cheddar
excellent
cheese oma this is you can see it's sold
out this is a top cheese right here the
oma
let's just see how much that one goes
for i hope these aren't crazy
um
18 dollars
for a half pound that's pretty pricey
actually okay so these are not these are
not cheap but see the thing is
oftentimes you'll go to whole foods and
it's on sale
bridgeman oh blue cheese should be
illegal definitely don't get that
um
the moses sleeper this is another
absolutely top cheese right here moses
sleeper incredible cheese
incredible cheese let's see what that
one goes for 29
oh my god
i must be just finding these on sale i
would never pay that
moses sleeper it's a great cheese
bailey hazen blue okay like if i have to
eat blue cheese it's not a bad cheese
and the winnemere is a great cheese as
well as you can see many of these are
sold out in fact they're sold out of
almost everything if it were me and i
was determined to try something i would
order a harbison right now that's an
excellent excellent cheese and then
lastly now i i'm willing to skip this
recommendation because it's almost too
pretentious or i'm willing to give you
like if you really want to come off as a
completely pompous prick i will give you
maybe the best pompous cheese
recommendation right now do people want
it or do i skip it this could be i could
lose a thousand members
maybe if i recommend this but i'm
willing to do it
people want it oh people don't want it
okay fair
no then we'll skip it nobody wants it
fine
oh people do want to see okay ready this
is now this is this is like
you got to be really careful with this
okay
here we go
gray barn
martha's vineyard
okay
this i'm gonna give you two of the top
cheeses i've ever had
not this one this blue cheese let me
find them
okay
not the bluebird no not this one okay
proofrock
this is
i would give this thing 10 or 12
different awards if i had them to give
out
incredible incredible cheese
also i can't speak to any of these
others the banane verser
this is a washed rind cheese
incredible now they say fresh summer
peach notes i sensed apricot i didn't
sense peach if i'm totally up front with
you guys
but the bon ani versailles and the proof
rock these are cheeses
like nobody's ever seen it's it's uh
it's really something
all right we're standing by here let me
get through some of these other twitch
thank yous though before we fall too far
behind sam the sleazebag
has resubbed jen here has gifted two and
then re-subscribed
also thanks to wind-up cat dark warrior
wow dranoa just gifted five
thank you
ms frazzied
and jen here with another two folks
that's putting us at 12 already and
we've only just gotten started
we also have today
um the coupon code sinks and showers
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers the coupon code sinks and
showers will save you 69 percent at
joinpackman.com we love twitch subs but
twitch keeps a large share
on our website we keep all but 2.9
okay so the most direct way
the most pleasant way to support the
work we do
is to sign up at joinpakman.com you can
use the coupon code or not it's up to
you sinks and showers is the code we're
looking very strongly at sinks and
showers very good okay other super chats
here
um blessed are the cheese makers what's
the deal with people not wanting to wear
masks or be vaccinated because it's not
100 effective right yeah it's all it i
don't understand it
it makes no sense
give me something that will protect me
it's like a seat belt was is not going
to 100 keep you alive but i'd rather be
wearing it if i get into an accident
favorite string cheese recommendation i
don't have any unfortunately i'm glad
you understand the truth about blue
cheese yeah a lot of people aren't
willing to tell the truth about blue
cheese but i am and it's not good
david sir have you seen the report that
19 out of 20 of the most popular
christian facebook groups are run by
foreign trolls haven't seen it but not
surprised
david will you be doing voicemails today
i left you one yesterday we're still
about a month behind on voicemails so
even if i did do voicemails it's not
mathematically likely that i would get
to yours today but we will eventually
probably in like four to six weeks we're
really
really behind on
those um thank you to
symbolicgamer
and
nikki206 for the twitch subs putting us
at 14.
jen mckenzie says david i make a
delicious creamy gorgonzola gnocchi that
would blow your mind blue cheese is the
best oh i don't know
detonation says from the standpoint of
sir
sir i think you're doing very well do
you obama in the shower
yeah
all right
very good let's listen to what's
happening remember we have two rallies
today first we have republican gre glenn
youngkin and that'll be followed by uh
democrat terry mcauliffe they're running
against each other
running against each other and we're um
keeping an eye on both of these
okay
what else
um
[Music]
all right let me move on to my next
thing here
that we already did
oh okay yeah this is pretty bonkers i'm
not into violence like this
i'm against this but this video is going
viral this is an anti-mask lunatic
harassing people and some guy just comes
out of nowhere and pops them in the
mouth this is going giga
viral when you discriminate
you're going to [ __ ] your restaurant up
so threat the guy makes a threat first
i see you just
please he's back
then he threatens this guy starts
getting getting ready
pushes him and some guy just comes up
out of nowhere and pops him it looks
almost like his contact lenses flew off
his face
[Applause]
[Music]
now that is a crime obviously obviously
that's a crime that's not how i would go
about resolving things
but um
it's like at this point how can anybody
be surprised that you have to put a mask
on to go into a place like this has been
going on for so long
uh oh i'm told there's technical errors
here uh
with the audio
yeah it's a disaster so this is not
glenn young so we'll go when glenn young
can actually starts for people wondering
about the race the race is really really
close right now it's mcauliffe plus 1.7
on average but the latest poll from
today
um
one poll from suffolk university has it
as a dead heat
and then the virginia commonwealth
university poll has it as mcauliffe plus
three i think you guys already know my
perspective on this everyone must vote
if you live in virginia and are legally
voting i'm not saying go vote if you
don't actually live in virginia but
everybody who lives in virginia
absolutely must must
must vote very very important
welcome to tobes for re-subscribing now
six months on twitch very much
appreciate that
in all seriousness it seems like some
people are saying that the that
my website coupon code is actually not
working and nobody's used it so i'm
actually worried it's really not working
this is not a bit let me actually take a
look
uh okay so
yearly sign up
sinks and showers
it's working fine what are you guys
talking about it's working fine
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers yeah
exactly elements of bathrooms people are
flushing toilets 10 times 15 times right
no it's working fine and i look forward
it's just nobody's signing up which is
actually worse i'd rather it be broken
because it's less embarrassing to be
totally honest
okay
all right a few other
super chats
sir have you watched the comey rule on
netflix i haven't i should
bernie sanders having a live address in
an hour oh okay i would go to that next
so we've got quite an agenda today we've
got the glen yunken rally let's see if
the audio's figured out
[Applause]
so this rally's going and then in a few
moments we'll have the terry mcauliffe
rally and if somebody can tell me oh
here we go
looks like they got a video player now
right
all right so this rally's getting going
so this is great everything's running on
time if anybody can get me video of uh
what will eventually be the bernie event
i will cover that as well that's
fantastic we've got a lot of great um
a lot of great things going on yeah good
okay i wrote the damn bill exactly so
maybe a little bit of bernie later
um sir could you check with our friend
kenny too we did it we did an event with
stephen kenneth destiny bonnell ii
yesterday normal there were so many
memetic moments
but um
it didn't make it onto
um
it didn't make it nothing made it onto
his subreddit so it must have not been
very very good so i don't we're not
going to do it today i think we've done
enough of that
for the week
thoughts on gop claiming issue with
january 6 being no national guard in
place on the record when did it become
common well it's so but the crazy part
is
trump resisted sending in the national
guard it's like they're mad at democrats
for not having the national guard there
but then
they also like trump was
actively saying no no resisting because
he wanted the entire thing to go on uh
they're just bad faith people that's all
it is are they doing a prayer is that
actually what's going on right now
directed by the power of your holy
spirit how did i know just from seeing
the guy's demeanor that there was a
prayer going on
that's
fascinating um
jonathan brown goatee yep doing a goatee
just i'm just bored
that's all
doing a goatee what i actually could use
a recommendation on
is i've tried everything to not cut this
area down here when i shave i have tried
nivea sensitive skin foam and i've tried
it before showering and after a lot of
people think you know when you do it
when you use the sink in the shower
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers they say you always want to do
it after it'll it you won't cut yourself
cutting myself with it's like an
irritation it's razor burn i think
then i got like a um avino gel
apparently it's like the best
before the shower after the shower
disaster
disaster so if anybody has any real
advice i've tried like the three razor
thing the four razor thing the five now
i'm on a german
just standard safety razor platinum
coated safety razor um double-edged
safety razor yes that's what i mean it's
just it it's just it's this disaster
it's a disaster but yes i'm doing the
goatee just for kicks right now
i can't thank enough people who are
getting me out of an embarrassing spot
is this the national anthem hold on a
second
what so proudly we hailed at the
twilight's last gleaming
whose broad stripes and bright stars
well catch your breath there sister
sherry samson just signed up on my
website with the coupon code sinks and
showers brian brostick just signed up
with the code ryan walton is a new
member sean irwin
and jose pacheco all signing up on my
website
thank you so much putting us at 20 as we
stand by for the first of two or maybe
even three
events
tonight have you tried an electric razor
yeah i don't i don't like it i don't
like it and it's i don't like it i don't
know why
david i've been watching your show for a
year became a member in august using
coupon code billions love the bonus show
keep up the good work sir thank you
as an autistic person with food
sensitivities i took offense at the kids
menu comments
google say what
oh come on this can't be real right
i'm talking about picky eating kids get
guys come on
i'm just i'm gonna move on i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna deal with that daniel says
unhinged leftist wages war against kids
menus yes exactly
thank you and welcome to kathleen jacobs
kathleen signing up with the coupon code
sinks and showers we're looking very
strongly at sinks and showers new member
number 21 today let's see now what the
next thing is here
you know
i was going to talk about terry but then
i remembered something i was told a long
time ago when i was a little girl and
it's that
all right we're still this is like the
fifth person to speak before
glenn actually does
um
i was gonna go to the mcauliffe biden
event tonight but i'm gonna go to a
concert instead all right have fun
and you don't like pie no i'm not a big
pie guy
sir i fixed me a nice cheese plate
provolone comte camembert with grapes
and fig mustard from ticino i felt as
pompous as it gets bon appetit that's
nice yeah provolone i don't really think
of provolone as a cheese for a cheese
platter but it works cumte tremendous
cheese camembert love it grapes fig
mustard also i'm partial to
uh
apricots dried apricots or apricots as
your preference maybe a few slices of
apple
big thank you to trools azim who just
signed up on my website with the coupon
code sinks and showers new member number
22 today
very much appreciate that
why did i not salute the anthem it was
unpatriotic yeah i apologize for that i
apologize
um let me see if i had a couple other
things here oh while we're waiting here
is uh our friend zach petrizo who
announced today that he is going to be
moving over to the daily beast from
salon
he has been covering glenn yunken
and here is where um he was covering a
yunkan event and a yunkan supporter just
went over and punched him in the hand
check this out
look at this guy right here ah get rid
of that thing you stupid fool
so that's illegal that's a crime
you guys go home
do you know of a single person who
disappeared under the cover of darkness
during the trump administration the
current of dark so very severe severe
mental illness uh clearly going on as is
the case unfortunately with a lot of
these people undiagnosed
certainly untreated and it's as much a
commentary about our health care system
as it is about political extremism
um
sir use a loofah i suffered for years
until suffered what kind what does that
even mean oh do you mean for shaving
i thought a loofah was like for the back
luffa shaving let's see
what is that what does that even mean
like do you mean one of those horse hair
things
loofah shaving oh what's this
let's see what this is this is an
interesting i don't think i've ever
heard of this
tea tree luffa shaving
what did you just rub this on your face
before shaving
that sounds interesting actually
i could get a lotion stick
has anybody try is does luffa mean
something like this what are you just
kind of foam
hmm
that's not bad all right i'd be willing
to try that
someone can recommend a good one
um
i don't want to be suffering that's for
sure
i want to say a big thank you to matt
wegerman for signing up on my website
with the coupon code sinks and showers
thanks to alexander faircloth or fair
khloe i don't know it could be either
way
thank you to steven shriver
as well as deontay jones everybody using
the code today sinks and showers we're
looking very strongly at sinks and
showers putting us at 26. also
huge thank you
over on twitch people using their bezos
bucks user j.p de beast already exists
says i love you david love you too
a new member number 27.
uh
whatever you do
don't let your bezos bucks stay in jeff
bezos pocket
if you have an amazon prime subscription
every month you can give five dollars
of which we only keep a fraction but
okay
uh it comes out of jeff bezos pocket
okay give it to somebody doesn't have to
be me but you got to spend that money
because otherwise it just stays in uh
it stays with you know who
sir my local market wants 9.49 for a
pint of graders 949 must be biden's
hyperinflation
i am thrilled that this has been brought
up listen to this you guys aren't going
to believe this
um hold on african black soap i'll get
to that in a second that's edgy material
i want to i want to make sure i give
that the attention it's due also i want
to make sure we don't miss either rally
good all right we haven't missed
anything yet
uh
about a month ago
i was asked about ice cream
and i said guys i have come across a new
extraordinary ice cream
and uh this was not a sponsor it's still
not a sponsor and the ice cream is
graters black cherry
chocolate chip or chocolate chunk or
something like that okay
um
i went to the supermarket two days ago
they have about five flavors of graters
okay they've got black raspberry they've
got vanilla
they've got whatever it's fully stocked
then there's i'm like where's the black
cherry
there's a price tag black cherry
it's empty
they had they had no black cherry now
i'm not saying i caused that by
announcing this new era of black cherry
where cherry garcia is out
and graeter's black cherry is in
but it's a little suspicious that it's
the only one that's sold out okay
now
it's like five bucks a pint six bucks a
pint
i got an email yesterday from a viewer
who said david sir
you can just order it
and so
i went on this website
which is the graders website and indeed
you can you can get a six point pack now
it's eighty dollars
it's eighty dollars that's like 12.50
per pint
that's highway robbery how how is that
it's twice it's more than now it is
kosher
which is great but this is twice the
price of what they sell it for it's ma
it's it's it should be illegal but just
so i mean the flavors look really really
good
i was actually thinking of maybe
ordering a multi-pack i would probably
do
pumpkin ooh some of these flavors should
be illegal black cherry chocolate chip
would definitely do that
um
caramel macchiato seems interesting
chunky chunky hippo that violates hippo
actually i can't get that
uh what else would i even get none of
the oh okay dark chocolate brownie dark
chocolate brownie looks fantastic
i would get a lemon sorbet just to have
it on hand so i could offer it like at a
dinner party that's a good idea
maybe a vanilla if you have it you know
with one of those chocolate lava cakes
oregon strawberry sounds interesting i
might oregon strawberry and then maybe a
vienna coffee i might order a six pack
it should be criminal though to sell ice
cream at these prices to be totally
honest
um
should be illegal should be illegal
i want to say thank you to dinan cleo as
well as felix rj
for the twitch subscriptions numbers 28
and 29. very much appreciate that guys
um
okay now let's go to this next super
chat try african black soap as a lather
for shaving it since using it no razor
burn okay so either loofah or african
black soap that sounds interesting
um be sure to go with the neck grain and
only ones with the neck grain
which way does the neck grain go
oh wait a second i think i might be a
complete idiot
does the neck grain go up towards the
chin
because if so i'm going against the
grain every time no wonder i'm cutting
myself right i'm a complete idiot
i'm i'm shaving backwards
all right i gotta go back to the drawing
board holy that's insane i've been
shaving wrong the whole way
it's the way that it is on your neck
yeah it's pointing up
the this is real i just got oh my god 12
people just cancelled because i don't
shave the right way
well i'm gonna that that would probably
help and then you go across yeah you're
never supposed to go completely against
i know you get a cleaner shave going
about wow
that's actually maybe the best advice
tonight i'll report back david sir
if you're
having trouble shaving your beard i feel
bad for when you have to shave your
apple bags oh my god that's edgy and
aaron says i'm not seeing any graders
black cherry in massachusetts let alone
northampton that's tough
that's sad actually
that's really really bad
um
okay good
all right let's see which of these
rallies is going to start first
um it's funny the glenn younkin rally
was scheduled for 45 minutes before the
terry mcauliffe rally
it's still they may still end up
starting either at the same time or
let's see who's this
it's a whole procession of people
let's listen in a little bit while we
wait for glenn younkin
nancy pelosi with her big fridges and
all that ice cream
all right so
basically on brand there as far as that
goes
uh let's see what else i had to go over
oh here's a madison cawthorne video this
was on the floor of the house today
he seems to be particularly unhinged
madam speaker today i am calling for the
creation of a formal commission to
investigate the true origin of covet 19
the role fauci played in its creation
the false statements he made to members
of congress under oath and why the hell
americans are funding the torture of
puppies in africa americans deserve the
truth and this demon doctor must never
be allowed to escape justice xscape
um madison cawthorne had a shot of
expresso and then
came out against escapes from justice
completely out of his mind um probably
has committed i actually
should be investigated should be
investigated to see
what crimes he may have committed
i'll leave it there okay thank you i
want to say thanks to kai bergson for
signing up on my website with the coupon
code sinks and showers we're looking
very strongly at sinks and showers also
thanks to teresa everett for signing up
on my website new members 30 and 31.
um so we're we're soon going to switch
to a different coupon code
is there a particular trump phrase that
you think would make a good coupon code
that i should consider oh thanks to
stinky magic for the twitch prime
subscription as well
obama obama
yeah that could be a good coupon code
bigly
i mean i have
surrounded by
water big water ocean water we could do
prompt
then he went donald trump yeah donald
trump
um
[Music]
that's not bad
china yeah
china
that could that could work
um
your wife is up in the air yeah that's
long though sir he's better than i am oh
wait no that's wrong hold on i don't
even know what i'm doing sir
sir your wife is up in the air yeah
there you go um the wettest from the
standpoint of water let me see if i have
that here
i don't know if i do
what would it be under because i've got
big water it's like how did i file it
oh here it is
one of the wettest we've ever seen from
the standpoint of water that could be
that could be something
convalescent plasma
[Laughter]
there's a lot it's really hard to say um
but people seem to like that yeah so
we'll see we'll see we'll have a new
coupon code soon i think it'll work fine
um okay while we stand by oh hold on i
missed the super chat swearing ceremony
and cabinet shuffle for the trudeau
government today but this has nothing
on your live streams come up to montreal
peace and love from up north
yes i did not cover that that's true
um
that's very very true all right i see
people who have been demanding
voicemails this entire time let's do a
couple voicemails while we
wait
uh for
the start of this first rally
waiting for the principles to appear
uh let's start with uh eric from mass
with another um admonishment
hey david it's eric from mass uh yeah
the conspiracy guy the guy who told you
that ivan akton works the guy that uh
just watched joe rogan take the living
[ __ ] out of sanjay coop to life that
never happened on tv he had to admit
ivan mexican works
um uh oh gotta go get some more money
from the uh pharmaceutical place got a
cover
get that new car well all you do is sit
inside and do [ __ ] nothing and tell
everybody else what to do while they get
brain damage from uh masks and uh stuff
like that and get all your followers and
all your dummies to um get your
followers we kill themselves through
baths and vaccines but whatever has
anyone ever seen a death even alleged
from masks like there there's people
alleging thousands of deaths from
vaccines and it's a lie
um
i've not even heard it alleged that
someone died from a mask that's
interesting then we've got our friend
whitney
so um
i know like some of the people that work
for
um
like the entertainment industry they're
like that's great uh then we have
oh i think this is the eggman we haven't
heard from the eggman for a little while
hi dave you know uh kyle rittenhouse he
murdered a couple of liberal protesters
and then
um uh
mike pillow paid his bail and a lot of
people paid his bail to keep him out of
you know jail for a while and that's
kind of reprehensible but um i think
that's a bad thing but after hearing
steve scalise speak on fox news this
weekend like you know say
trump got cheated all that stuff
i was like i'm going to donate money to
the guy that shot him james t hodgkinson
i'm going to put money on his books in
federal prison
i was wondering if that's as bad but as
i'm doing it i realized that the guy is
dead that he was killed
during the incident so i can't send him
money but do you think if i did send
james t hodgkinson money and he was a
federal inmate that's as bad as bailing
out kyle rittenhouse for murdering
people
um because steve kelly to the person and
he did try to murder him
thoughts
am i a bad person
yes but not because of this is where i
would come down on it
so um
i wanted to call in regards to defunding
the police
because
okay i have a story about all right
we'll get to the story on a different
day
this is i believe this is a mexican
accent i think i've immediately
identified this is not certainly not
argentinian not from uruguay it's not a
chilean accent it's not a puerto rican
accent it's not a dominican accent it's
not a colombian accent so from the
accents i'm familiar with this is a
mexican accent which i love actually um
is he talking about the dr
is this wow i guess i gotta this does
not sound like a dominican accent
hmm
this is like unlike any dominican
republic accent i've ever heard
[Music]
oh my god
oh my god after all these nice words and
saying how the woman who called about
the vaccine is ignorant he said some one
of these days i'm gonna get the vaccine
what
what are you waiting for
what are you waiting for wow it was a
beautiful call up until that moment
hey by the way how funny is it that this
reporter's standing where where he's in
shadow like there's just a shadow right
on his head now we're we're southern
virginia pretty much central in the
state if you kind of come up from the
raleigh durham area about an hour and a
half that's where we're at right now
yeah so they're really struggling to get
this rally going which is bad for them i
want to say a huge thank you to hunter
waters who just signed up with the
coupon code sinks and showers also thank
you to nora hurley for signing up new
members 33 and 34. i very much
appreciate that today's coupon code on
my website is sinks and showers and
it'll save you 69
um
i think you should have whitney on the
show
that would be interesting no trumpkin
for coupon code vote blue virginia
henson shavers it's not about creams
it's about the blade henson shaver is
about 70 bucks built to a tolerance akin
to the space shuttle wow
um
i'm gonna have to look into that let's
see
henson shaving
okay
wow
looks pretty nice
but it's like they seem to be using the
same 10 cent
blades everybody uses i don't know um
okay we'll look into that
we will look into it
amen about kids menus my kids now in
their 40s ate everything and never had
to be coerced it's a bigger issue than
food choices it's about entitlement and
we have too much of that in our culture
burn the kids menu
nancy pelosi and her fridge is full of
ice cream please be careful with the
dairy recommendation sir the right
strongly disapproves
david sir look up a shave map it may
help
okay i'm not going to google that right
now because that could be could be
problematic
um but i will look at that off stream
oh let's listen to this uh supporter
family your work
or everyone you know for this candidate
lincoln yes
are everyone you know for this candidate
that's that's a grammatically uh
jumbled isn't it
2016 and 2020 of virginia voted for
barack obama and and for uh joe biden uh
respectfully in those years this guy's
actually the caterer someone just handed
him a mic and he's like what i'm
sunburned i shouldn't even be here
and voted for a republican president
we're turning red
tuesday thanks for your time thank you
very much and that's some of the things
i heard before we came on is that people
are if that's so this guy's grammar is
weird
that's some of the things i've heard
isn't it those are some of the things
i've heard that's weird people that
they're going to keep messaging to what
needs to change in this state now true
conservatives i would think about 94 95
percent of those conservatives backed
this candidate
it's the independence in the moderate
democrats as what really could swing
this election because right now it's a
dead heat and we've got what seven days
left uh next tuesday night is the
election here in virginia so we'll see
how that goes let me step aside set the
scene for you you're now joining us we
are live in danville virginia okay so
that's this is the yunkan rally and then
the opponent terry mcauliffe will soon
be speaking
um
this is tim kaine right let's listen a
little bit i've got to get better
framing here i don't even know let's see
what's the right shot
i don't really have a good shot set up
for this
uh let's see
maybe let's listen to a little bit of
tim kaine
[Applause]
but he's going to be eclipsed
by governor 74 terry mcauliffe
[Music]
it is so great to be with you raise your
hand if you have voted already
i love that
raise your raise your hand if you still
plan to vote
wait no some of you raised your hand
twice
i like the arlington spirit
okay that's pretty funny uh all right so
that's going on there and we're standing
by we're standing by for both both
candidates
um
okay good very very good
thank you to dr halo man who just
resubscribed via twitch prime see we
have that up there now latest sub it'll
show up automatically dr halo man
um appreciate that very very much your
new member number 35 today
which is a great number to be
let's keep going with voicemails while
we wait here
hey david it's angie from milwaukee
something dawned on me last night i was
talking to a friend who is a trump
supporter and she went to the trump
rally in iowa
um i just listened to what she had to
say because i know there's no way of
changing her mind
but it dawned on me that
they see supporting trump as some
great thing for america and it makes
them these great people right they see
themselves as essentially soldiers in a
in a moral war she told me how everybody
there was so nice
and how great it was to be surrounded by
other patriots
and
that
it's
actually it's not just politics it's a
movement that's exactly that's exactly
right they see themselves as soldiers in
a war
and when you're at war
sometimes you got to do
things you wouldn't ordinarily do which
is how they justify lying
how they justify violence that that's
very interesting angie that you saw that
first hand
very interesting
but i um i checked up like the
definition of extortion again and it's
like
bribery or like intimidation
and
um
okay yep uh here's another
recommendation mercure razor
astra superior platinum blades i've
tried that exact combination aaron
it didn't go that well for me
it didn't go that well for me
uh okay
hey david
so who does steve bannon think he is he
thinks he can just
you know dodge a subpoena from congress
even in the movie like the godfather
you noticed you know the the crime
bosses had to come to the senate
you know i had to come to the senate and
appear but yeah no that's uh that's
absolutely true
hey david i was uh watching a clip on
fox
and uh lindsey graham was
in an interview and he said 40 000
brazilians are at the border
headed for connecticut wearing
designer clothes and gucci i was
wondering if you had any comments on
this it
sounds pretty scary
yeah
it's very gucci bags are super scary i
have no idea where tucker got that and
it happened like i think i was either
off or or it was over a weekend
and i ended up just not not even talking
about it it was really weird
so um
i was just wondering about like history
as far as like english and jewish
relations yeah english jewish relations
have been great
hi david how does chris kirsten cinemas
betrayal of her constituency of the
united states
by not by
not doing what she campaigned on
doing and holding up common sense
reforms uh change
the kind of uh
aspects behind like doubt to vote
and and these this messaging you here
where it's like
you know
it's lack of participation it's uh
apathy political apathy that are causing
uh these issues because
these people
okay
hey david i'm a big fan of the show um i
recently heard you have blood work done
um just want to let you know that i'm
hoping for you
[Music]
praying for you
and um just thinking about you all
around and hoping you get better and uh
no there's nothing to get better it was
just routine blood work
uh
it was
i appreciate that though thank you
so i'm like thinking back again to
um
ancient england
and just like as far as
um
you know the jewish people having like a
violent complaint of exertion of royalty
i'm trying to think of like in context
what that could mean
because
um
you know
like before jesus was born
like you guys had a book of rules that
like made you jewish and then
on top of that you had like more rules
to enforce those rules
and it i mean like in reality the book
came from egypt so there was obviously
somebody who was watching you yep they
actually were watching this this stream
um nora hurley says eva gloss razor
bumps solution works wonders on shaving
irritation
fur oil also a shaving staple ideal for
beards and pubes good luck lol thank you
norah i appreciate that
um we're gonna look at all of those
products
really
really strongly
um let's see how things are going still
tim kaine no terry mcauliffe yet and uh
just random stuff here let's listen to
some interviews with supporters
we appreciate your time thank you for
your thoughts there you go that's kind
of what we heard
uh from a lot of people was they want
the power back to them uh you know we
talked about coven mandates the shutdown
i mean a lot of everybody wants have you
guys noticed that everybody wants to
feel really special now like they have a
re they're they're they have a really
special reason
for thinking really deeply and coming
out in favor of glenn younkin or against
or whoever and it's like
you just go and vote you know there's a
little too much built up in the story
about the importance of your vote every
vote is important but the idea that
there's been some major
you know i decided that it was just time
to stop the socialism and we've got to
bring back power to the people and it
just has to you know so so that's why
i'm here that's why i'm here to look
okay all right that's good i mean
but it's a little there there's like a
self-importance
day it is a dead heat
uh a lot of people
from even from the left are predicting
that yunkan can pull this out because
the momentum is definitely on his side
let me turn around and see what we have
going up throwing some swag out there
all right so he'll probably be coming up
soon i want to say thank you to coiny
coiny's bunker
coin is bunker for signing up via twitch
prime
very much appreciate that thank you so
much if you're just joining us we have
competing rallies in the last seven days
before the virginia gubernatorial we
have the radical right-wing candidate
glenn younkin lunatic and then we have
just boring milk toast democrat terry
mcauliffe a much better option but not
something to go crazy about but
obviously a much better option very
important that he win
um
and looks like we're getting very close
to both i don't know
who do you guys think is going to
actually end up speaking first
the young can rally was scheduled for
much earlier
but uh it looks like it in both cases
we're getting very close to the
principles
showing up
um
all right
couple of oh thanks to hanging from
gallows for the twitch prime
subscription number 37. i appreciate
that okay let's listen to the commentary
i just something about this is so funny
on that go to
mypillow.commystore.com oh my god and
find some quality products
guys you have two options for coupon
codes today okay
you can go to the mic pillow
uh website
and save 66 percent that's one option
okay
or
you can go
to join pacman.com
and get 69 off with the coupon code
sinks and showers we're looking very
strongly at sinks and showers
your choice
okay
that's one coupon code possibility the
mic pillow
that's another coupon code possibility
you know where i'm where my mind is on
this one
okay
uh as we stand by for both terry
mcauliffe and glenn
younkin um
healthcare workers can't opt out with
testing isn't that an infringement on
our freedoms no you have the full
freedom to work or not work anywhere you
want you have the full freedom to say i
will only work at places where you don't
have to be vaccinated um that's
completely your choice you have full
freedom
and your employer also has freedom
everybody everybody's free
dave be sure you prep your skin get it
soft before shaving prepping does
wonders yes we i did address that i did
address that
that is an important oh oh boy
we just lost our super chats
see if i can get them back
that was
disappointing there we go they're back
okay
got ugly for a second there
um all right let's do a few more
voicemails here
uh
here we go
hey david uh big fan here uh enjoy
watching your show and i really
appreciate the uh the weekly covet
updates um it's been a
a good source for me to spread some good
information thank you i very much
appreciate that that's terrific
sorry just a quick question so oh this
should be a professional voiceover
artist
this is an absolutely perfect voice
you guys hearing this you can tell we're
only two seconds in but it's very this
is a perfect voice
hi just a quick question so i'm seeing
some backlash for biden regarding the
shutdown with the um
with all the ports being blocked up and
um not having enough truckers to get
supplies where they need to go
and it's um it seems to me that
it's just a natural consequence of covet
and
you know it's a multi
it's got many reasons for why it's
happening
but i guess i was just kind of wondering
if you hadn't done any research into
whether this can be squarely laid
at the feet of biden or if this really
is something that
has been a long time in coming it's not
just been a long time coming it was
literally happening during trump
continuing on what i was going to say
about like self-control but also like
thinking of forgiveness because like if
jesus came down to forgive the jewish
people for all their sins and stuff like
that
i don't remember that part of the bible
but i'm not an expert i admit
hey david this is jesse in ohio and i
was thinking about this steve bannon
thing and uh if the guy gets on a
podcast and spouts the truth
every day for an hour or so or whatever
why wouldn't he go to congress and stop
the truth under oath
perpecting problems anyway thanks for
what you do man
yeah bannon's bannon's horrible there's
a lot of questions about bannon
so uh do you think of that um
the german farmers voted for hitler
during the holocaust because the jewish
people don't
like eat pork and they don't
um they regulate the amount of like meat
versus
dairy products like you can't eat dairy
and meat and uh
like meat together like the cow
wow that's interesting that's very
interesting could german pork farmers
have voted for hitler
because they were angry that the jews
weren't buying their pork because the
jews don't eat pork that's an
interesting quo i've never thought of
that i've never thought of that
hello david my name is kieran and i'm
phoning from glasgow in scotland kevin
is kevin
like kevin is that the same name kevin i
love that
um
my first introduction to
american culture was when i was a kid
watching maybe maybe uh top new caller
of the year
wwf wrestling
and that kind of defined from what my
opinion of
america the american public and culture
okay don't assess the country's 331
million people from fake professional
wrestling please don't do that kevin in
general
um
when i watch trump rallies from before
he was president up until now i can't
help but
see some parallels between some of the
people that
go to his rallies and his supporters
they have somewhat of the same behaviors
i wonder if there's like a point where
his same peaks
much like any other kind of famous
athlete or entertainer would peak
and what that would mean for each
following
uh yeah that's a fair question i mean
has is it just the decline from here or
is it going to build back up for 2022 i
don't know it's it's a completely fair
question uh i just i just think we don't
have the answer yet
we have another speaker speaking in
advance of terry mcauliffe now
and i also want to give our special and
very personal thanks to dr joe biden for
all she's done for our country whoa not
a medical doctor though is that even
legal can they even do that i know
they're very very concerned with that
thanks to mckinley
for signing up via twitch prime new
member number 38 today very much
appreciate that
bay photo says ticker symbol for trump's
spac should be
grft
yes very well done
very very well done nicely nicely said
um
let's see what else we've got here
hey dumb heap i just wanted to call you
out for spraying misinformation and
out wise on your channel whoa
now i think this is the person who calls
from an unblocked number
and who we've identified as well as
his employer
and we were just talking like should we
call his employer and be like oh yes it
is it is it is it is oh we know exactly
who this person is yeah we were thinking
of like should we report the fact that
this guy is doing this to his employer
off
oh for attacking for being an ah at a
stage five trump arrangements
syndrome sufferer and the emp
yeah and
attacking people
who on the right who happen to be bigger
than you just like kansas
owens ben shapiro and
and many others they are smarter than
you and you know that you just
are
you're just a [ __ ] cloud chaser as
far as i'm concerned now go [ __ ]
yourself i actually imagined this guy
making the calls while at work
which is which is fascinating
uh okay all right so then so we got that
guy fine
um
let's see what else we've got here
uh
we've got one more whitney video a call
oh so i read um or i watched your video
about uh donald trump um maybe turning
back against
um
the election
and feeling like even if he wins he's
like losing because he like doesn't
understand like how he could have lost
um
like
in the same boat right now with like
court and stuff like that um just
not really understanding
um
like how
i want to say thank you to alice
maravillas or as we would say in
argentina maravishas which would mean
marvels
thank you alice alice now subscribed for
six months and his new member number 39
today
let's go back and listen to sunburn guy
tell us a little bit about what's
happening here so don't forget to follow
us on all of our social media getter
we've been blowing up on getter and of
course jason miller
just months ago we've seen it's one of
the fastest growing social media
platforms so if you're not following us
on getter follow us all right terry
mcauliffe is speaking he's speaking
before anybody else so let's go
thank you for coming tonight first of
all
i want to thank thank you everybody
oh hold on i'm gonna try to fix the shot
okay bear with me everybody thank you
first of all let me thank my wife
dorothy and i want to thank her for
being such a great first lady of the
commonwealth of virginia the best
partner in my life and most importantly
for making sure that 13 million more
meals were served to needy children here
there we go
[Applause]
i thank you congress and buyer who was
with us our great speaker eileen filler
corn was with us senator kane our great
governor ralph northam phil hercorn i've
never heard that last name that's a
fascinating what's the origin of that
thank you
to our future lieutenant governor of the
commonwealth of virginia holla is in the
house with us
and our future attorney general who has
done a great job mark herring's also in
the house with
so folks you give me a democratic house
with this team let me promise you this
state will take off like a booster
rocket let me tell you
and first of all thank all of you for
being here today what a beautiful
evening here in arlington virginia to be
here with the 46th president of the
united states of america joe biden
wow
[Applause]
virginia
we have only one week left in this
campaign
and i gotta be honest with you there
could be nothing more at stake
and sometimes you have to slow down
and take a step to realize what really
is at stake
and yesterday was one of those days
yesterday
glenn younkin released
his closing argument of this campaign
in it
he promotes an effort to ban books by
tony morrison from virginia schools
there you go there's an idea
[Applause]
one of america's most famous authors the
winner of the presidential medal of
freedom
the winner of the nobel prize
this
is his closing message
glenn
is promoting banning books by one of
america's most prominent black authors
true
true that's true
[Music]
just the fact that his evening
brings shame here to the commonwealth of
virginia
he is ending his campaign the way he
started it
with divisive dog whistles
even after the deadly attacks on january
6.
glenn young launched his campaign by
promoting election conspiracy theories
and for eight months it was the only
issue he had on his website
he incurred speculation that donald
trump could be reinstated to office
then he went donald trump his campaign
surrogates include conspiracy theorists
who promote violence and lies about the
2020 election
yeah as unexciting as mcauliffe is
yunkin is a lunatic extremist
[Applause]
but folks he campaigns on radio shows
with supporters of neo-nazi groups
that's true
so virginia we have a choice
a path that promotes conspiracies hate
and division or a path focused on
lifting up every single virginian
i have 20 comprehensive plans
166 pages in all to tell you how exactly
i'm going to do it how i will lift up
every virginian
there is a real difference in this race
i am a uniter glenn younkin is a
divider i promise all of you we will
create good jobs in every corner of the
commonwealth i promise you we will raise
the minimum wage to 15 by 2024. whoa
i promise you we will make child care
more affordable for every virginia
family
and i promise you i will get every
virginian paid sick and family medical
leave here in
virginia that's a promise folks we're
going to fight the high cost of
prescription drugs
we really can't allow virginia to go
back to democrats it would i'm sorry to
republicans it would be really bad
because remember the current democratic
governor is term limited so this was
like an assumed seat
and
um
if terry mcauliffe barely
if he barely wins it's not great but at
least it's been held
um
this is this should be like a plus 10
and it's dead even it's dead even right
now
so i rolled up my sleeves i got to work
making life better for all virginians by
working in a bipartisan way i'm proud we
created 200 000 good paying jobs
personal income went up 14
and we've reduced unemployment in every
single city and county here in virginia
[Applause]
we leaned in on clean energy to tackle
climate change and create good paying
jobs
and glenn younkin
the other day he denied that humans
contribute to climate change
and he just said he would have blocked
virginia's clean economy act are you
kidding me it's quite a contrast folks
we made a record investment in education
infrastructure and transportation that's
why we are consistently ranked the best
state in america for business
is that true i didn't think that was
true always
always try to find common ground
as you know i will work with anyone at
any time
including reasonable republicans
supposedly terry mcauliffe will actually
ban the virus and end the pandemic in
virginia which is cool i mean just just
ban it just do it just make it illegal
and it's not just banning books and
election conspiracy theories
it's issues like education
glenn younkin wants to file donald trump
and betsy devos's plan and take money
from public schools and send it to
private schools
independent reports have said that his
plan would cut 43 000 teachers from our
schools here in virginia
and what bothers me daily is that glenn
young uses education to divide virginia
he wants to pit parents against parents
parents against teachers he wants to
bring his personal culture wars into our
classrooms
folks we will not allow glenn younkin to
bring his hate and his chaos in our
virginia schools
it's kind of weird though that mcauliffe
hasn't told us if he's for or against
the coronavirus
instead here's what i'm going to do for
you
i'm going to raise teacher pay above the
national average for the first time in
virginia history
i promise you within two years i'll get
every single student online
and i will expand pre-k to tens of
thousands of children in need here in
the commonwealth of virginia
glenn younkin
has done nothing but run down our
teachers since this campaign started so
let me say this to all the teachers here
in virginia
we love you
we appreciate you and you are the true
heroes of this covet crisis
on coven
glenn younkin has already brought donald
trump's anti-science agenda to virginia
and think of it he's not even elected
junkin has said
on day one
all masks are off and no vaccine
requirements for our teachers
maybe you can maybe you can't i'm not a
doctor folks this is deadly
here in virginia
1142 of our children have been in icu
beds in our hospitals
last week two 11 year olds died from
coven
we cannot let glenn younken be in charge
of our children's education for their
health
[Music]
and on abortion
one thing is crystal clear
glenn younkin
has stated over and over that he will
outlaw abortion in virginia and let me
say this donald trump supreme court will
now let him do it
this isn't a hypothetical anymore
women and doctors could face jail time
women will die from unsafe illegal
abortions here in virginia
let me be clear
i trust women to make their own
decisions as i did before
and i will always be a brick wall to
protect women's rights against
politicians like donald trump and glenn
younkin who want to make abortion
illegal
so folks we have one week to go
we've all got a lot of work together to
bring this one home our campaign so far
has already knocked on 1.5 million doors
thank all of you last weekend we knocked
down over 150 000 doors last weekend so
thank you
but make no mistake i still need your
help
i need you to get out i need you to vote
early
i saw senator kane folks that that voted
early i need you to join the 750 000
virginians who have already cast their
ballot please i need you to have your
voices heard early make sure you go out
and vote and you vote early
and folks if you got an absentee ballot
at home send it in please
you cannot take voting for granted
because as you know there are people out
there who want to limit the right to
vote
it was only a few years ago
that i overturned a 102 year old racist
jim crow era law that prevented those
who had served their time from voting
restoring voting rights
to more people than any governor in
american history was the high point of
my governorship
[Music]
[Applause]
let's briefly jump over to his opponent
glenn younkin and we'll come back for
joe biden in a moment listen to this guy
where we all get to change the
trajectory of this great commonwealth of
virginia not just for virginians not
just for those that live here but for
the entire united states of america
everybody's watching us everybody
everybody is watching us because we all
believe we know that
we need to be able to march forward in
the relentless pursuit of a better life
of of prosperity so it's not blocked and
and and inhibited by
politicians who were more interested
about their own advancement their own
success as opposed to the people that
they were elected to serve
we see a culture today where we're told
that we should accept
we should accept low standards we should
shelve hope
friends virginians are just flat saying
absolutely not here any more that's
what's happening all over the
commonwealth of virginia
what's this guys this guy talking about
friends this is no longer a campaign
it is a movement it is a movement where
we are all standing up for our children
for our grandchildren for our nieces for
our nephews we're actually standing up
and saying we have a fundamental right
to be engaged in our kids education we
have a fundamental right you understand
the code huh parents decide the
curriculum as if they know as much as
teachers mental right to make decisions
about our lives as opposed to having big
government making them all for us that
means no vaccination mandates this is
all code for horrible policy come
together as virginians and unleash
unleash the virginia promise a promise
where we soar as virginians we don't
settle
a promise where we in fact can get
virginia where we know she needs to be
the best place in america to live and
work and raise a family
this is what's in front of us but it
hangs in the balance right now
right now it hangs in the balance
because over the course of the next
seven days
virginians are going to make a decision
and we're going to make the decision on
which way this country and this which
way this commonwealth are going to go
now over the course of the last eight
years we've seen elections have
consequences
and the consequences for virginians have
been dire they have and boy the last two
years the last two years it's been
crushing we've watched the left liberal
progressive leadership in richmond try
to turn virginia into california east
and we are just not going to have it
funny because the state of virginia has
improved dramatically under democratic
governorship and and uh it's it's very
very funny so we're keeping an eye on
terry mcauliffe we're going to go to him
we've heard from him already we're going
to go to him when joe biden takes the
stage we're listening to a little bit of
glenn younkin now this is the race seven
days to go washington thomas jefferson
james madison
john monroe
patrick henry it started here folks
i mean our nation's history is
virginia's history and our nation's
future is going to rest in virginia's
present wrong because we get to make a
decision
and that decision
is either going to be for big government
control or it is going to be for liberty
and i stand for liberty that's what
we're going to go talk about a false
dichotomy huh
[Applause]
friends i get asked all the time glenn
glenn what's that first day gonna be
like
and let's go on a walk together cause
i'm gonna tell you exactly what it's
gonna be like that first day on january
15th
where jason miara's who is going to be
our next attorney general
uh-oh
winston sears who's going to be our next
lieutenant governor
and i have the amazing privilege
the amazing privilege of standing under
mr jefferson's portico
and putting our hand on a holy bible
and swearing to god almighty that we are
going to protect and defend the
constitution of the united states of
america and the constitution of this
great commonwealth of virginia
this guy must be defeated my friends
must be defeated we're going to walk
down those steps we're going to walk
down those steps and and paige is going
to join jason and terence is going to
join winston and my amazing wife suzanne
is going to join me and we're going to
invite everybody else
who wants to join us to join us in a
moment of prayer oh god a real moment of
prayer where we stop and we thank the
lord for providing for us for guiding
for us
for provisioning
us in this campaign for protecting us
but then we're also going to ask him for
his guidance going forward to lead a
path we can walk wait a second his plan
is to do what god tells him and then
we're going to say amen together and
then we're going to work because we got
a lot of work to do to get virginia
moving
this guy's vile
uh let's check back in with the terry
mcauliffe event here's joe biden
it's time
it's time
one week to make those phone calls and
knock on more doors one week
to get out the vote
and one more a week
to elect terry mccall of your governor
of the state of virginia
[Applause]
you all know the stakes
and here are a few things i want you to
remember first
you don't have to wonder what kind of
governor terry will be because you know
what a great governor he was
that's a bunch of malarkey wasn't just
because of what he promised
is what he delivered
on his watch virginia's economy boomed
200 000 jobs created he made a record
edition of one billion dollar investment
in education
expanding preschool
and resources for public schools in
lower income communities and gave
teachers a raise
now i must say parenthetically the real
reason i'm here tonight
is
my wife jill teaches full time at
northern virginia community college
[Applause]
and terry's going to be her boss
[Laughter]
all right
terry stood by our veterans helping them
apply their skills and good paying
civilian jobs and feels like cyber
security and health care
funding for new veteran care centers
including the first one in hampton's
roads region look
he took on the gun lobby and enacted
sensible gun safety measures without
infringing on the second amendment
including helping keep guns out of the
hands of domestic abusers
not a joke
virginia you know terry
you know his record he was a great
governor if you re-elect him again he'll
be another four years as a great
governor but look
how well do you know terry's opponent
well just remember this
i ran against donald trump
[Music]
and terry is running against an acolyte
of donald trump true
terry's opponent
doesn't like to talk about how
very much now
but to win the republican nomination he
embraced donald trump
big u-turn he started his campaign by
saying that the number one issue in the
race was
has called the election he called for
election integrity
stand back and stand by
now why did he do that
because he wanted to hear
donald trump
it was a price he'd have to pay for the
nomination
and he paid it
but now he doesn't want to talk about
trump anymore
well
i do
[Applause]
talk about an oxymoron donald trump and
election
integrity i can't believe he puts the
word trump and integrity in the same
sentence
look he's done a lot of
lousy things
but my friend general colin powell died
his integrity
a man of incredible integrity
they certainly go together with colin
powell
and integrity a decorated american hero
which is why the attack
just leveled by trump against
general powell was so offensive
i'd say it's unbelievable if it's not
trump did the same thing about john
mccain
that's who donald trump is
all coming from a guy who invented the
big lie
drove a mob of insurrectionists to
breach the capitol on the 6th of january
and to this day
he incites people all around the country
he said he said the people who attended
his rally
and then stormed the capitol quote
they were peaceful people
they were great people
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm glad you're here
virginia you know better
you saw with your own eyes
many of you were there
some of you risked your lives the anger
the rage american flags turn into spears
a noose of gallows police assaulted and
killed
death threats against elected officials
and public servants carrying the most
sacred act of a democracy certifying a
free election
the breach of the capital
that didn't even happen during the civil
war
to donald trump
the insurrection isn't a violent assault
that took place in january six of the
capital no
to trump the insurrection was no the
november third election
i'm trying to manage the audio but it's
he's going he's getting very quiet and
very loud and it gets difficult terry's
opponent embraced
and it prompted the washington post to
write something about terry's opponent
every virginian should read before they
vote and i quote
glenn younkin has failed the character
test
he has indulged and encouraged
republicans to have swallowed former
president trump's lie
that last year's presidential elect was
stolen
mr younkin
chose to dignify
a fundamental fiction that is subverting
our system
rather than standing squarely for the
truth
in doing so
he proved himself
unfit for office end of quote
i've not seen many editorials written
that strongly in my career
heck
just a look how he's closing his
campaign
he's gone from banning
a woman's right to choose to banning
books written by a pulitzer prize and
nobel prize winning author tony morrison
my wife jill
my wife jill went to princeton to
interview her taught her book
let's be clear
this is a guy
you guys hear that there's people just
screaming somewhere they're probably
going to get kicked out soon right it's
very much at risk because of what's
happening in texas
if you want to protect a woman's right
to choose in virginia
you need a governor absolutely committed
to protecting that right
and terry has made it clear
he'll be a brick wall against anyone
trying to take that constitutional right
away
but terry's opponent
not only embraces
someone with such a lack of character
he endorses donald trump's bad ideas and
bad
record donald trump is the only
president since herbert hoover
in the 30s to see more jobs lost than
gained the four years he's in office
in just nine months of our
administration we've created more jobs
than any president has in the same
period of time in american history
when donald trump left office there were
only about two million people fully
vaccinated
in just nine months in our first year
over 190 million americans are now fully
vaccinated
trump i love this one
trump likes to boast the single best
measure of the economy is the stock
market i never thought that well if
that's true take a look at the stock
market now it's harder than it ever been
thrown
everything's doing well
not only that more people are working
today than just before the pandemic
started
household wealth is up people are buying
more things manufacturing is up
we're on the move but we're on the right
track we got more to do
so if you're looking for someone who's
going to keep your economy going and
growing the man behind me is the guy to
get it done not a joke
he'll do it again
in fact we're taking a page from terry's
book on his governor and when he'd be
governor next time
we're emerging from this pandemic we
want to expand peak pre-k for three and
four-year-olds millions of pre-care
that's what's in my buildback better
initiative
studies show that when you do this you
increase by 58 the chances of a child
will complete the rest of their
education in high school and beyond
and what better we want better roads
bridges than ever right let's just check
in as to how the opponent glenn
younkin's rally is going
it is not about me it's not about
winston it's not about jason it's about
us
and it's about us standing up and and
not and doing more than voting
it's more than voting it's getting in
the arena with us
because this is what virginians do we do
not follow we lead
it is that spirit it's that spirit of
jefferson and washington monroe and
madison friends patrick henry stood up
in front of the entire nation and
stomped his foot and said we will not
ratify that constitution
without a bill of rights
speaking very tangentially to anything
relevant to this race huh
and 400 000 schools in child care
centers in america that have lead pipes
including
their water
look folks
in america
every surrounded by every child
you should be able to turn on a faucet
and drink clear water give that guy a
drink of water will it
look
let me ask you this
is that a protest
20 years ago
a bottle of insulin for type 1 diabetes
cost 32 a bottle but today
the same exact same exact formula no
change cost
280 dollars a bottle not a joke
that's not only wrong it's immoral
some audio issues jerry wants to take
the drug companies and i do bring down
the cost of prescription drugs and we
can do that there are nearly
there are nearly two million
qualified women in america who are
working not working today because of
child care here in virginia
the average two-parent home spends
fourteen thousand
six hundred dollars a year for just one
child
we wanna bring those costs down so
working families will not have to pay
more than seven percent of their income
to care for a child under the age of
five
[Music]
[Applause]
we're going to raise the minimum wage
that terry is going to we strongly
support it to 15 an hour no one
no one working full-time should live
below the poverty line
[Applause]
how much house you ought to think about
terry's opponent
has made all of his private pledges of
loyalty to donald trump and but what's
really interesting to me
he won't stand next to donald trump now
that the campaign's on true
think about it
he won't allow donald trump to campaign
for him in this state
and i would love to see a trump yunkan
rally that's for sure
why not in public
what's he trying to hide
is there a problem with trump being here
is he embarrassed
look who's been here for terry my wife
jill barack obama kamala harris
stacey abrams and so many more
look
let me close with this
there's a fundamental difference between
democrats
and terry mcauliffe and what's going on
today's republican party not a joke
terry's opponent
number one
we stand for working people in the
middle class
[Music]
economics has never worked
we're both building the economy from the
bottom up in the middle out
today's republican party stands for
nothing but just keep cutting taxes for
the wealthy and the most powerful
corporations
second thing to remember here's the deal
for virginia democrats you've made
incredible progress in the state in
recent years on jobs the economy
healthcare education and attracting new
business growing the middle class and so
much more
for more than 40 years of virginia
it has been the democratic and
democratic governors who've led
you've made this progress because you've
had the courage and the wisdom to reject
the very extremism that has taken over
the republican party all across america
think of it republican party
nationally is for nothing
not a joke
nothing
not a joke just look around just look
around what's happening with the
governor of texas in florida
the assault on women's right to choose i
can't believe terry mcauliffe hasn't
announced whether he would ban kids
menus could have been saved
virginia
for the sake of your families and the
country we can't let this happen here in
virginia
extremism
can come in many forms
it can come in the rage of a mob driven
amount of salt driven to assault the
capital it can come in a smile and a
fleece vest
either way
the big lie still a big lie
so virginia show up
show up like you did for barack and me
[Applause]
uh-oh
what the heck
show up like you did for me and kamala
and show up for a proven leader like
terry mcauliffe show up
to protect the majority of the house of
delegates
to re-elect mark attorney general i may
lose power guys just as a heads up
virginia
you can't take anything for granted so
vote vote early get five of your friends
and family to vote
you can drop off your ballots and drop
boxes you can mail them in
visit
iwillvote.com to find out where and how
to vote early show up for democracy from
virginia for the united states of
america
god bless you all and may god protect
our truth vote vote vote vote
[Applause]
i got harry legs
and by the way maybe you could inject
some bleach in your arms that's a [ __ ]
[Music]
so this is one option and off goes joe
biden pointing to people
uh clinton really perfected the pointing
where it wasn't even really clear
whether he could see someone in the
audience but he would do this move where
he would go
and it was it was very uh you know it
worked for him
it worked for him for sure uh where are
we here here we are
uh okay so a few different folks uh on
stage
[Music]
wow
terry mcauliffe doing some dancing which
may be something not to do at this point
[Music]
[Music]
all right what's joe biden gonna do
he's going down into the
[Music]
crowd i don't care
anywhere
you could service very nervous
okay all right so now we'll go back over
to the opponent oh i guess it's over
butter
that might be happening in november
december and go online to my pillow dot
com my
they're in the my pillow segment of the
evening
and
shop and be proud that you're putting
your money in the hands of a proud
american an american that's fighting for
you and i
mypilla.com mystore.com thousands of
products right there on mystore.com and
don't forget to put that promo code rspn
at checkout and yes that's right you'll
get up to 66 off your entire order all
right so let's catch a little bit of the
bernie address which is live right now
real quick thank you to tick box
sarquart and yo samurai for the twitch
subscriptions get them in this is a day
to do it saying thank you also to
douglas gennadis for signing up on my
website with the coupon code sinks and
showers looking very strongly at sinks
and showers and also thanks to jacob
satterfield numbers 42
and 43 today uh let's see what bernie
framed with way too much headroom uh
someone should really sit him a little
bit higher but let's listen anyway
eyeglasses hearing aids and dental care
something that should have been done
decades ago
so here we are in a very critical moment
in american history
and the issue that we face
is whether the government of the united
states of america
finally finally has the courage
to stand up to powerful special
interests
and do what the american people
want yeah good it's true okay
that will be the case
thank you all very much
all right and then almost at the exact
same time senator bernard sanders
independent from
uh
vermont
um chiming in and ending his event as
joe biden is in the crowd meeting people
something joe biden loves to do it does
make secret service very very nervous
when he does this
[Music]
[Music]
very good okay
all right so we are heading towards
election uh one week from today if you
live in virginia please vote
please vote
and i don't know i mean listen i don't
know exactly how many votes it will take
or how many we will need i need 11 000
votes give me a break but everybody must
vote we will be here in one week
um 8 p.m eastern essentially seven days
minus 28 minutes from today
starting to get results from the
virginia gubernatorial as well as
mayoral elections around the country
i think we have
we have some other things going on on
that there's a bunch of elections new
jersey yes jersey of course
um
we'll have a full list okay so that's
the the that's a stream we know about
we also
i'll i'm sure i'll pop on before now
before then and do some other stuff uh
so thanks to everybody who joined me
today is the last day for the sinks and
showers coupon code on my website
joinedpakman.com
thanks to everybody who subscribed via
twitch super chats everything
vote vote vote
and we'll see you back here very very
soon